kourtney kardashian's daughter goes goth
she loves fashion already the keeping up
with the kardashians star's
nine-year-old daughter penelope disick
is sporting a brand new look just in
time for spooky season on sunday court
shared this snap of her little girl
looking rocker chic in an all-black
ensemble complete with mesh gloves and
temporary face tattoos a black heart on
one cheek and a small x on the other she
loves accessories she loves to try on my
shoes the mom of three who shares her
kiddos with her ex scott disick simply
captioned the post with a couple of
halloween themed emojis a black heart a
spider and a bat court's boyfriend
travis barker took notice of penelope's
transformation and called p a rock star
in the comments while p's aunt khloe
kardashian wrote quote she's so
cute but penelope isn't the only
kardashian jenner kid to go goth she's
just like a full goth girl last month
when kim kardashian stopped by the ellen
degeneres show she said her
eight-year-old daughter north is into it
too north is like goth she's into hot
topics and she dresses with like she
puts fake tattoos on her face and she
listens to black sabbath and last month
north showed off some temporary face and
neck tattoos to match her famous mom in
this insta selfie the kkw beauty founder
cut right to the chase in the caption
writing simply tats
having kids is just there's no way to
describe it but it's a lot
but back to court getting my house
together i'm in a major nesting mode
she's definitely in the halloween spirit
the pooch founder has already decorated
her house to the nines complete with
skeletons creepy pumpkins skeletons a
spooky table setting oh and did i
mention skeletons because that's the
push founder rocking a skeleton onesie
of course the kardashian jenners have
been known to go all out with their
costumes for the holiday
whether it's kylie as christina aguilera
chloe as cruella deville kim as tiger
king's carol baskin kendall as a
victoria's secret angel or courtney as
ariana grande they sure know how to do
halloween right